finding an opening to any movie is
always a challenge because you're kind
of setting the table for the movie and
story to come we had to remind the
audience that syndromes jet from the
first film destroyed their house this
was interesting because it said what
happened directly after that moment and
I imagined that they would have to
strategize on what they're gonna do they
don't have a house anymore they don't
have a phone this isn't a universe where
cellphones exist and they would have to
somehow get to a phone and halt dhikr to
come pick them up again and I think it's
funny it's kind of scruffy and flabby
because it's a version that we didn't
stay with very long it is kind of fun
and is interesting in showing how we
explore these ideas I hate to cut short
a tender moment but unless you want to
explain this to a crowd come on
[Applause]
this is your plan to hide in the bushes
of the Spratlys backyard I suppose you
think the cully's have better bushes and
no this is not my plan we need to get to
a phone right to call dicker right well
the nearest pay phone is pay phone are
we what do you think we should do knock
on the neighbor's door wearing our super
suits when they notice I'm gone just say
I went to call dicker okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]